pour obtenir un logement social en
touraine il faut remplir un dossier de
demande et c'est la commission
l'attribution de logements qui décide si
le demandeur rempli les critères requis
pour devenir locataires de hlm
seuls deux critères sont limitatif pour
en faire une demande de logement social
c'est il faut être en situation
régulière sur le territoire français
disposer d'une pièce d'identité ou d'un
passeport et ensuite avoir des
ressources qui ne dépasse pas les
plafonds l'attribution réglementaire
pour une personne seule ses 19 1834
euros de revenu fiscal de référence sur
l'année les noirs 2 ce qui fait environ
1800 euros de revenus mensuels
le rapport commandé par la ministre du
logement cécile duflot souhaite amener
plus de transparence dans l'attribution
des logements hlm
mais les bailleurs sociaux locaux
affirment qu ici il n'y a pas de
passe-droit possible en effet en indre
et loire
il y à 12400 dossiers en attente dont
plus de 80% sont concentrées sur
l'agglomération de tours on a connu des
époques effectivement il y avait une
grande tension sur le marché du logement
social et que certains certaines
personnes pouvaient y aura tendance à
vouloir insister pour le passer en
priorité tel ou tel dossier
on n'est plus du tout dans cette époque
là la mise en place du fichier commun
fait qu'effectivement tous les
demandeurs peuvent avoir accès à tous
les logements qui se libèrent ou
potentiellement inversement c'est tous
les bailleurs qui peuvent avoir accès à
toutes les demandes sur le fichier
commun de la demande et le fait depuis
avoir l'intention fait que finalement
les gens arrivent à obtenir d'ordre un
délai relativement correct une
attribution de logements en touraine en
moyenne il faut six mois d'attentes pour
accéder à un logement social
en effet rien de comparable à la
situation connue en ile-de-france
pourtant ce délai peut être encore plus
rapide si la demande est faite en milieu
rural